Disney stock on its way to worse years
since 1974 after Avatar sequel
disappoints this is market watch story
this is share saying nearly five percent
was nearly uh to its lowest level since
March 2020 on Monday after the
Blockbuster Sequel and one of the
priciest movies in Hollywood history
fell short of the hype in its opening
weekend Avatar the way of water hauled
in 134 million dollars domestically and
had the second largest global opening of
2022 but fell short of tracking
estimates on based on Advanced U.S
ticket sales and disappointed and won
the biggest markets for the franchise
China Disney had opened in open to uh
had hoped to clean
up in China where the first movie in
2009 did Blockbuster business the way of
water earned 57.1 million dollars there
which did think the scrap in a Wall
Street Journal report as disappointing
but understandable the problem is nobody
wants to go to the cinema because
they've been told that covet is
extremely dangerous Tony Chambers Disney
Global head of theatrical distribution
said Tom what are your thoughts on the
story well first of all this is why
Disney has a new CEO folks this is why
Bob Iger is back in doing a uh his own
version of uh you know a reality show to
rebuild the house so the avatars can be
just fine and I think this can be the
biggest movie of all time if you think
about everything you have to do to put
on an event it's like we do the Vault
event here at uh valutainment you you
can't move the date you can't change
things there's hotels there's travel
everything is in place this movie was in
place and no one could have predicted
just how big World Cup was going to be
number one no one could predicted that
kovid would have another wave come
through and China starts telling people
to stay home or that you would have
civil unrest in many parts of China over
Apple labor practices at those factories
yet yet so I don't look at it this way
oh Avatar didn't meet expectations I
find it kind of unbelievable they did as
much as they did against those headwinds
so they got a new CEO they got this one
thing I think Avatar is going to be just
fine I think this is going to be sitting
there at number one one
when everything is counted later on this
is the biggest movie biggest box on Pat
you saw you saw it right yeah I did did
you like like if you and I'm a movie
buff I haven't seen it yet I heard I
heard two conflicting sides from
Maverick and everybody they said
Maverick said it was three hours and 10
minutes he goes they didn't need that
extra 10 minutes after three minutes or
three hours your body's like okay what's
going on what are you from from rating
it from storyline I mean Graphics I mean
they've had 15 years with technology
what do you what would you give what
would you rank the movie I I listen I
thought the the story was great it
started very slow you know they had to
kind of bring you back obviously the
maybe the reason was because it's been
so long I don't know I think the movie
could have been done in two hours and 40
minutes it didn't need to be three hours
and 12 minutes I would have been fine
with two hours and 40 minutes I agree
I'm okay with that part uh it's very
emotional at the end the story is about
how your kids eventually lead your
family and parents end up needing kids
to rely on which is a very emotional
message that the way he did it it was
very very there he talked at your heart
constantly for the last 40 minutes I
mean I've walked out of movies so many
times in the first half uh half hour one
hour done if you do that with this movie
you'll be disappointed because the last
30 40 minutes is worth it here's the
other part China of course makes sense
for them to have the kind of numbers
that they have so they can't be
disappointed with that you can't do
anything when politics get involved in
China that's not the movie's fault
that's not Cameron's fault he says we
need to make 2 billion to break even
that is an insane number to say they
need to break even here's the other
thing that nobody is talking about on
why Avatar didn't hit the numbers you
ready Avatar came out the weekend of the
World Cup yeah who the hell is talking
Avatar nobody I mean you got three
billion people that watch the World Cup
give or take little over three billion
people you think three billion people
are sitting there saying so Adam what
did you think about Avatar if Avatar
would let me give you a prediction if
Avatar would have waited one week on
when to come come out they would have
done numbers and even more they screwed
up on timing what are you doing coming
out on the weekend of World Cup like
honestly Mr CMO whoever the CMOS what
the hell were you thinking yeah did you
look you know the calendar you know when
the World Cup freaking is you can't
change it one weekend yeah you can't go
one weekend before or one weekend after
like I thought the timing of it was out
of whack but I will tell you this
I think this number is going to there's
some people that are upset with the fact
that they showed pregnant Warriors I
don't know if you saw that or not
they're already getting that much yeah
the wall mob is starting they're already
talking yeah if you want to like the the
uh the whole concept of you know uh no
not the woke mob the the yeah exactly
the whole like they wanted a pregnant
Warrior to say Hey you know we wanted to
kind of highlight women yeah we felt
sympathy for women pregnant so we want
to say that pregnant women can be
Warriors up fine I understand what he's
trying to do I don't think it makes any
sense uh to be quite Frank with you I'm
sure back in the days you didn't have a
choice
if you were having to fight and I do
believe back in the days if a pregnant
mother had to be forced to protect her
kids she probably would have fought uh
so it may not resonate with the average
person today uh I was talking to
somebody the other day who said you know
my mom gave birth to me I said yeah my
mom also gave me she says no no you
don't understand my mom was walking and
all of a sudden you know she's not in
America she's living in Mexico I was
born
and she's holding me with my umbilical
cord and she went to the neighbor and a
neighbor who was half blind no joke cut
it and that's how I was born now today
if you say that to the average person
what would they say what an
irresponsible mom what's wrong with it I
mean a thousand years ago everybody was
doing that it's not like you were going
to the doctor calling Blue Cross Blue
Shield saying hey can I set up my
c-section that was none of that a
thousand years ago it's a different time
so a little bit of reach there was no
lgbtq type of a thing where parents can
feel safe about that part when they're
watching this James Cameron didn't play
the games with that I do think this is
going to end up making a ton of money
and it's not going to slow down that's
what I would say about Avatar well it'll
hit HBO or something within what a month
uh I don't know I've got a movie
recommendation for the people out there
um this might be a little controversial
uh we're talking about Avatar we're
talking about Black Adam you know how
what number are we on on The Avengers or
whatever don't listen to this message if
you have kids if you're married with
kids or you know if you're taking your
girl on a date night but if you're a
dude out there you're 16 and older yeah
here's what movie you should watch this
year
zero movies okay if you're working and
you don't have money saved up you're not
in shape you're 20 pounds overweight you
haven't done a business plan yet you
don't have a chick in your life you're
not doing anything you don't have a
purpose you haven't done your business
plan you haven't done anything you get
to watch zero movies this year you get
to watch zero Netflix shows this year
there's no video games for you this year
until you clean up your act there's so
many men out there that are watching
movies that know that they're on
Avengers 17 they're on Superman seven
they're on Spider-Man 19 I watch zero
movies you guys are talking about Avatar
that's great you've got kids respect the
kids need to see that if I don't have
kids or if I'm not on a date night of my
girl there's no movies for you you're
struggling homie like I'm just saying
most dudes out there two two out of
three people in America living paycheck
to paycheck you don't get to see movies
until you're off the paycheck to
paycheck wheel that's my opinion I
haven't gone I haven't gone because
there hasn't been anything worth me
watching but I mean I'm on a complete
opposite I know you know I'm a movie
buff me Mario test me all the time Mario
will say
when it comes to hip-hop I stopped with
Biggie and all them back in the day and
then when it comes to films but what I
mean kind of I I I would go if it was
good but off of Adam's thing how
expensive is for for 3D how much is the
ticket popcorn food drink for one is
perfect one person's experience how much
is it bad for 3D I can't even tell you I
don't I don't know I buy the tickets
online and at 14 bucks 15 bucks 20 bucks
no I think right now they're like for
for what's what's a 3D no 3D soda and a
popcorn I'd be willing about national
average about 30 bucks because I think
that's gonna be like a 19 ticket right
that was gonna say at least a 20 14
bucks there you go this is for regular
yeah regular ticket yeah but that's Matt
nay so it's one o'clock for 3D I heard
it was like almost forty dollars really
plus everything yeah you have to wear
the goggles and all that [ __ ] it's not
cheap bro so I can see where Adam's like
every because I mean some people watch
two movies a week there you go
20.43 there yeah
performance 10 bucks and a drink you're
spending 40 bucks easy for one thing
that's it for a person I can't afford it
that is insane I I don't I don't
disagree I will tell you for me when I
was broke and I was busting my ass
movies were my therapy uh uh for me to
go to matinee get away from everybody
and watch I Am Legend with a form of
Escape without needing a therapist yeah
movies have uh uh uh have done that for
me but we understand Adam is an
unorthodox type of guy he doesn't
believe in driving yeah he has his horse
parked outside he comes in uh Tom you're
trying to say something on the movie
side I think you were gonna say
something no I am but I will
um you know I think there's a lot of
movies out there that are not exactly
family friendly and I I'm really
thrilled to see Avatar
um my girls my kids they love the
Marvels they love the Avengers they love
that series
um we love Top Gun so there's there's
glimmers of Hope in there that are
movies but I agree with Pat you know you
look at it like this I think a movie is
a great experience and I think it's an
uplifting experience because you you
drop down into an immersive story and
you get to look at the story and it
touches you I am Legend things like that
and I I disagree I think movies is a
rather cost effective escape and you to
your point Vinnie you don't have to go
to the 7 30 you know um Friday night you
know you know high def theater with 3D
for real D and then you gotta pay for
the glasses and everything you know you
you can you can go to standard theaters
and enjoy it but I think it's an Escape
there's positive messages it stirs your
soul stirs your thoughts I'm on that
favorite movie of all time give your
favorite movie uh me it's Godfather too
okay what's yours
Good Fellas what's yours Jaws it's yours
anything with Vince Vaughn swingers
swingers
what do you got what about you I mean
Godfather too I would put Man on Fire
probably Gladiator I'll put Gladiator at
the top I can watch it here's my point
those movies are like they don't make
movies like they used to it's all just
marvel I agree nonsense yeah I agree
with that yeah and by the way to you to
your point because I know you have
strong feelings on on movies when you
were going because you've told that
story you'd go by yourself yep
what phase of your life were you in at
that point 27 years old okay yeah so
here's where I'm going with this you
were in your building phase you were
creating a company you were working at
uh wfg at the point you would yeah so
the point is this your Escape for those
two hours because you need to decompress
for all the [ __ ] you were dealing with
this is the one you were in the Army
this wasn't when you were at Bally's
this is Army we would watch movies in
the barracks you're making 600 bucks a
month dude you can't do a lot of things
I feel you on that yeah but I guess my
point is this
it if you're like for instance for me
I'm I'm reading I'm watching YouTube I'm
reading articles I don't watch any TV
but if I need Escape I'll watch a half
hour of Seinfeld or whatever yes I do
agree you need some Escape so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks right if you believe future
looks bright get your latest Future
looks bright hat of valuetainment it
says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]